maintenant j'ai un cadeau un
exceptionnel anjou d'exceptionnel c'est
un cadeau douce et pour cela j'ai envoyé
mon peu fidèles maxime guide bombay dit
j'ai pas dit que c'était le meilleur
juste que c'était le plus facile on va
regarder la vidéo d'une association
qu'on a reçu et moi je vais vous
retrouver sur l'autre plateau dans un
instant c'est parti regardez la vidéo
regarde c'est enfin on nous ressort que
le père noël français nous cette année
on compte sur vous on veut aller dans un
parc d'attractions moisi amateurs et
nous essayer nos jours
[Applaudissements]
une série
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci d'être là plateau magnifique
pas le magnifique merci à vous d'être
avec nous merci ça va un peu mieux
qu'ici on a encore des cadeaux pour vous
mes chéris merci les amours on va
accueillir tout de suite caroline vigie
qui est la directrice de la
communication de la fondation actions
enfance actions enfance a que des
enfants en danger au sein des villages
d'enfants et leur permet de se
reconstruire de grandir entre frères et
soeurs voilà ce sont des enfants
traumatisés 1 par des drames familiaux
c'était très très important pour nous de
les aider ce soir parce que actions en
france accueillent accueille plus de 750
enfants france dans quinze villages
d'enfants et foyer d'adolescents est ce
qu'on peut couper le micro des
chroniqueurs là bas s'il vous plaît
merci c'est juste une tranche à baisser
merci à paris alors cette fondation elle
a beaucoup beaucoup de missions comme je
les dis hein sont des enfants
traumatisés par des drames familiaux et
vous leur venir en aide le fait un
travail exceptionnel et ce soir vraiment
vous voulez vous soyez avec nous parce
qu'on veut vous aider
on veut que ce noël pour ses enfants
soit 1,2 leur plus beau noël et voudrais
vous remercier nous d'avoir fait appel à
nous merci à vous vraiment et je vous le
dis des personnes comme vous les
personnes comme il ya dans l'association
voilà on en a besoin et vous fait un
travail exceptionnel tous les jours on
est dans le divertissement
on rigole on essaie voilà de divertir
les gens mais vous vous faites un vrai
boulot et franchement bravo
alors
on va essayer de faire gagner des
magnifiques cadeaux aux enfants
je vais vous dire ce qu'on va faire
gagner parce que ça va être énorme et
pour tout public aussi il y aura des
cadeaux joly
j'ai préparé ma légendaire potion
magique qui est ici regardez elle est là
c'est ce qu'on appelle de la mourir
d'accord les chéris je vais demander à
maxime de s'installer au dessus du
chaudron bien sûr le signer merci mon
chéri mon maxime je sais que je peux
toujours avoir confiance en toi je sais
que je peux toujours compter sur tout
caroline pour faire gagner ses enfants
je vais tenter de tirer sur la cible et
tenter de faire tomber
maxime maxime est ce qu'on peut la soie
rapidement mais dit si tu lui parlera
quand il sera chez lui merci comédie lui
raconte ça du tout par toutatis
merci à mon chéri caroline vous voulez
alors vous êtes vous êtes magnifique en
plus je vais pas vous faire essayer si
vous l'essayez c'est vrai alors caroline
essayé voyez regardez vous avez zèle
butin
[Applaudissements]
hamid et zohra comme ça on va marcher
sur l'eau il essayait de trouver de
tirer sur le bouton rouge
pardon alors me suivait allez-y ouais
c'est pas l'autre et c'est dans la bonne
direction
c'est dans la bonne direction si vous
avez des bas est ce que dans le public
il ya quelqu'un qui voudrait nous aider
quelqu'un qui joue un petit peu au foot
kaka qui joue un petit peu au foot dans
le public ya quelqu'un là quelqu'un la
kia qui à monsieur oui oui oui mais
désolé monsieur
du coup bon coeur
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai
j'adore
alors on se regarde un peu nos coiffures
parce que c'est vrai qu'on est un petit
peu dans le milieu de la coiffure et du
sport je sais que j'adore merci je kiffe
de ont fait recette ça te va très bien
que ça des antilles ou des séries
d'amour c'est djibril et je voudrais le
dire c'est un mec exceptionnel à chaque
fois que j'appelais pour une association
en vrai il est toujours là c'est un mec
qui a un coeur énorme que j'aime
énormément de skull ils seront de
nouveau là il n'a pas de preuves on est
bien juste pour le kiff et il vient
juste pour aider les enfants tu es
vraiment un amour merci alors tu vas
essayer de faire gagner des enfants
battus aux tirs
je le dis parce que c'est comme caroline
ont caroni de rire d'un côté de moi car
vous c'est comme quand tu vois le bouton
la sao maxime sceptiques comme un assez
petit je sais que ces petites attentions
bon masi et cinq ans et à ne pas pas
quoi [ __ ] en l'air dans notre carrière
au haut niveau c'est non et djibril
cissé
immostar mme c'est pas trop s héros en
fait trembler grand patron la tête quand
même pas mais c'est pas loin c'est pas
loin
jibril doivent alors être à côté moi
c'est pas grave c'est pas là est-ce
qu'on a quelqu'un d'autre dans le public
qui vont essayer ce qu'on a quelqu'un
d'entier au pkk d'autres chez moi une
fille une fille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma chérie
merci d'être là toi aussi tu es toujours
un amour voilà je le dis très
franchement voilà peut-être fait plaisir
de voir l'or toujours nova lors
dénuement joueuse aussi l'or tu vas
essayer de faire gagner votre pass pour
les enfants alors les pieds nus et d'un
homme bien sûr tu peux te moitié du
vanni c'est toi plaisir mets toi à
l'aise mais elle a voulu faire la bogoss
belle quand elle gagne les potes et
justement pâle s'est dit oh tu vois je
veux quand même dire la bo de la bogoss
alors et julien après ce qui lui aura
gagné pour l'association et pour le
public c'est non mais non c'était très
belle comme ça aussi je te le dit vas-y
machin attention à s'accepter gauche
comme chez vous vous avez déjà taillé
quant à ses retombées
quel gosse belge quel gosse belle base
e-motion
[Applaudissements]
les cherry ou des stands des loosers
c'est difficile c'est pour ça qu'on en
retrait ce qui est encore une troisième
personne peut-être qui veut nous donner
une troisième personne ne sait pas dans
tous les cas pas quelqu'un les champions
c'est qui
[Applaudissements]
hier
merci merci
en plus de sa qualité wallace atx de ouf
merci d'être là frérot merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu présent merci au psg
alors frérot il ya des cadeaux à faire
gagner pour les enfants je sais que tu
joue la ligue des champions je sais que
tu gagnes des championnats mais là chez
des cadeaux il ya un truc rouge là bas
les mecs et franchement choupo ce que je
sais qu'ils sont aptes au moins t'as pas
le chou pauvres ouais ça ça va je sais
mais en fait si alors tu sais quoi
essayer de nous faire gagner c'est
cadeau il a plusieurs essais ou pas
cette société ce navire la taille d'un
accord ça je sais que la taille
d'arbustes c'est pas ça mais c'est déjà
tu veux pas l'autre
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est très dur il peut le
faire il est quand même petit l'autre du
poil offert fois
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soleil
c'est gagner mon chéri d'amour mais
chérie je vous le dis il ya des cadeaux
exceptionnels tout le public et les
enfants de la fondation actions enfance
par dans le plus gaulois des parcs
d'attraction pour la première fois le
parc ouvre ses portes pour une saison de
noël exceptionnel 40 attractions
attendent et quatre spectacles le visage
de la glisse avec des patinoires des
pistes de luge allez kiffer pour noël et
j'offre également voilà tout ça aux
enfants de l'association mais caroline
ont quelques jours c'est noël et avec ce
cas trop franchement merci à djibril et
merci à l'envers
[Applaudissements]
là je vais dire avec ça c'est sûr que
claude jegat la ligue des champions
c'est sûr avec 7 a fait oublier c'est un
joueur exceptionnel
alors on peut se soigner qui pensaient
se paye ce péché on sait pas alors
marseille peut-être l'année prochaine on
verra
j'ai envie de faire plus ce soir a
demandé une surprise et cette surprise
c'est que pour les enfants de
l'association
on va offrir mille jouets pour les
enfants
[Applaudissements]
le président la grande récré pôle enfant
je quittais fabrique aux agro méga bleus
vtec époque d'enfoncement des rôles-clés
gk santos dernier l'ovale à tous
ils se sont tous associés à nous pour
aider l'association la fondation actions
en cours caroline dumas vous dire
exceptionnelle syriens sont à prévoir
je redis par rapport à ceux qui font
toute l'année pour les enfants c'est
rien du tout on voulait juste voilà vous
aider un petit peu parce que voilà c'est
vrai qu'il faut beaucoup de moyens
et voilà on voulait jouer en a besoin
c'est surtout les éducateurs familiaux a
lâché moi je les représente cependant
bien sûr nation mais c'est toutes les
personnes qui s'occupent au quotidien
jour et nuit de ses enfants et qui leur
donne des repères pour se reconstruire
et donc c'est surtout à eux aussi un
grand merci
voilà des traders ou et merci beaucoup
merci très fort au gp c'est sûr que pour
l'atmosphère ou d'amour que jeanne
j'espère te voir merci mal leur boulot
d'amour canton d'anglès et commerciales
totalité